et maintenant qu'on a vu comment bien
manger pour noël on va voir comment
récupérer tout ça alors avec moi j'ai
scellé à cabris bonjour on va parler
cros suite avec vous donc venu pour en
parler avant de commencer tout ça c'est
d'aller voir ses adeptes
je me suis rendu chez farmer training
une nouvelle salle dédiée au crossfit
qui est ouvert en septembre à la ferme
des bizouard à plaisir ça semble fut
conviée du coup via mon métier faut que
j'en entraîné du coup le crossfit ça
mélange de thau jim haltéro endurance
cardio
du coup c'était bon compromis quoi ça
change tous les jours on n'a jamais le
mot donc du coup il n'y a pas de rang
qu'est née de l'attitude voilà en fait
jamais l'exercice c'est la surprise les
joueurs ouais mais du coup c'est
toujours des bonnes surprises parce que
bon voila quand on est motivé pas
forcément ça fait que l'on vient et puis
voilà on verra c'est comme le cadeau du
père noël en cours on déballe on voit ce
que ça donne
alors comme nous l'ont dit les deux
sportifs il ya un programme différent à
chaque cours dans le jardin crossfit
on appelle ça un gode pour world out of
the day une super accent anglais c'est
quoi exactement expliquez moi comment on
fait les programmes ça change vraiment à
chaque fois exactement en fait il ya une
programmation qui est fait sur le moyen
et long terme
nous on sait où on veut amener les gens
où on veut comme enlever les éduquer au
niveau sportif et du coup après en
divisant petites séquences et donc
chaque jour est une nouvelle séquence
pour justement faire progresser la
condition physique générale ensuite
généralement ça semble très intense pour
moi même voir un peu des images ici vont
bien mais c'est quand même adaptés au
niveau de chacun
exactement c'est ça la magie du crossfit
en fait la magie du crossfit c'est que
on peut être débutant on peut être un
peu initiés on peut être élite
on peut être handicapé on peut être
blessé toutes les toutes les solutions
sont possibles en fait chaque mouvement
va pouvoir être déclinée pour pouvoir
réadapter à chaque personne en fonction
de son livre c'est pour se maintenir en
forme pour aller encore plus loin
vraiment en finition des poivres des
attentes différentes en attendant un
coup de crosse fils exactement alors
vous avez comme une petite particularité
c'est que en plus du crossfit vous
ajoutez du yoga exactement alors le yoga
c'est quelque chose qui va permettre de
travailler beaucoup plus en profondeur
on va travailler beaucoup plus le
gainage on va pouvoir travailler la
souplesse l'équilibré des choses qu'on
travaille un petit peu moins en crossfit
ou de façon plus rapide alors que l'on
va vraiment prendre le temps yoga est
aussi prendre le temps de travail et sa
concentration est vraiment le retour sur
soi qui permet justement d'être encore
meilleurs après sur les autres activités
comme le crossfit non mais nous ce soir
on va pas se détendre en faisant du yoga
je pense qu'on va essayer le crossfit
moi j'invite mes collègues à me
rejoindre les plus téméraires encore
moins des meilleurs spécimens de la
rédaction
alors je vous ai préparé un petit cadeau
au pied du sapin sa part voilà donc
comme là vous avez aimé les jeux un
matériel qui s'appelle le catel belle le
catal belle qui est donc en anglais ça
veut dire une cloche en eau et qui est
lesté donc qui pèse un certain poids
donc il ya plusieurs tailles pour
plusieurs
oui avec le petit déjà eros poli fille
n'est ce pas le 8 et 12
et comme je vous disais donc quand vous
arrivez dans la salle vous avez donc un
programme un nouveau programme tous les
jours une fois c'est un mode du jour
tout à fait ça c'est un walk out of the
day donc là nous avons 4e round 4 tours
donc on parle toujours en anglais en
crossfit ok c'est le code comme le code
de la route c'est voilà donc qu'on parle
en anglais
nous avons 80 on de 9,6 top 6 gobelets
de squats et trois birdies le jargon
et que je vais vous expliquer c'est très
simple les filles se sont mises en robe
et ont fait exprès et en talons en plus
pour ne pas pouvoir faire certains
mouvements tels que le site appelé
j'aurais dû nous allons aussi des noirs
et établit le sitap on peut se placer
donc sur le dos sur le dow les filles
les filles vous avez vite et du coup on
voit les garçons sur le dos sur les
gosses vont me donne tout à fait clic le
micro et tous ses prêts c'est parfait
mes pieds les pieds jean fléchit les
genoux en ouverture là vous allez amener
les pieds l'un contre l'autre
de cette façon oui le plus insensé
encore nous montrer vos amis est
d'accord vous saviez vous alliez faire
du sport non non non martèle estime je
bougeais vous trouvez un autre cobaye à
toucher loin derrière et on va ramener
mais non c'est pas fifty
mais non mais non d'ailleurs avec la
baisse c'est une base aux non ça ne veut
pas je ne peux pas faire ça vous fait ça
très bien
grégory voilà qu'on en fait trop face au
café
donc ça c'est le site up ok ça veut dire
ça allait s'asseoir en fait tout
simplement
ok très bien pas mentionné michael fabre
avons rénové
mon dos ne suis pas au bled squattent
les filles vont pouvoir le faire
tiens je vous en prie aime est squatté
1,8 kg alors nous tenons nous tenons le
cattle comme un gobelet donc entrer
demain
voilà d'où le nom gobled quoi tard pour
memphis de l'autre des pieds larges hard
et des épaules et nous allons faire un
squat le squat c'est la flexion des sang
et or remonte jusqu où est ce que c'est
le pantalon le problème on imagine qu'on
a un gobelet entre les mains il faut
surtout pas le faire tomber
il est rempli d'eau bouillante
c'est plutôt bien surtout je me rends
compte que vous n'avez pas dit encore là
donc ça ça je peux le faire
prix juste et jean oui alors on place
les monts en temps ça va être compliqué
mais mais non en tant que danseuse
reparti à ce flamenco
alors on pousse les oranje légèrement
vers l'arrière et ensuite on plie les
jambes on descend des savants des
savants décemment dès sa naissance et
bien bravo belle mobile très très bien
donc ensuite vous pouvez poser et nous
avons le fameux beurre puis
internationale que tout le monde adore
n'est ce pas si on ne parle pas du tout
mais c'est vrai nom est bon et bien le
beurre puis emplacement au sol donc on
grenouille en grenouille s'est couchée
par terre
ah bah oui on y retourne bien annonçait
alors donc nous en avons neuf du premier
six du deuxième et trois du troisième et
donc ensuite nous avons quatre tours à
faire en tout ça c'est la routine c'est
une routine possible donc on y va on
essayait quand même mois aux mamans
alors non
au moins un tour mais pas ici on peut
nancy c'est pas grave les filles vous
allez faire un gainage à la place
regardez voilà comme ça là c'est plus
simple pendant que les garçons ils font
les six textes on y va je ne peux pas
faire je ne vois pas ça marche
ok tu es parti allait bien la première
faire de gens n'ont rien à neuf en effet
les habitants voilà donc là il faut bien
expiré pour aller vite monté voilà pour
repose sur vous grégory mais alors le
problème c'est que si ma lentement les
filles attendant non mais un peu non
mais je fais plus haut je pense qu'il
reste trois là encore 2 encore un ok le
prochain tour sera plus rapide
ok ans qui skiait un coup s'interrompre
en lego on prend les quêteurs et on fait
les gobelets squatté par geoffrey assez
bien fait intime c'est bien allez c'est
parti en a six on y va et tac est
remonté deux c'est parti 4,5 et 6,5 et
ans repose on fait les beurs peas y en a
trois pour tout le monde c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
échauffement échauffement continuera
hors antenne pour la suite de avec
plaisir
[Musique]